[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and the
CEO of total politics group Mark Wallace
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the sun leads with a new line of inquiry
in The Disappearance of Nicola bully
reporting that police are pursuing the
possibility that she may have tried to
retrieve her dog ball from the river
wire
that element of the story is also the
main line for the mail
Rishi sunak is preparing for a legal
battle to stop migrants who've crossed
the channel in small boats from
appealing against their deportation
that's on the front of the tines
the guardian hears that a former foreign
office official is to sue after being
sacked for giving an anonymous interview
about what she perceived to be the
government's mishandling of the fall of
Kabul to the Taliban
the telegraph says the government
intends to make online misogynistic
abuse a crime
according to the eye there are renewed
Supply problems with hormone replacement
therapy drugs which are affecting
millions of women across the country
the express quotes excerpts from Boris
Johnson's TV interview with his former
culture secretary Nadine Doris in which
he says he believes the conservatives
can win the next election especially if
they cut taxes
the financial times reports that the
ftse 100 share index reached an all-time
high today
the mirror says a celebrity special of
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire has been
put on hold after three women allegedly
refused to work with Jeremy Clarkson
following his article about Meghan
Markle
and the star has the story of the West
Midlands Village apparently being
terrorized by an aggressive owl
reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Susie
Boniface and Mark Wallace welcome to you
both um let's start with the story of
Nicola bully um a terrible story that
we've encouraged very very sad story uh
indeed the front page of the Sun
pointing to this riddle of the lost dog
ball that they're now looking at
Susie
yeah I
there are lots of
Pizza country who are horrified by this
and who are also playing armchair
experts
and
you know making out that they have some
kind of insight when the police and the
family and the people that are there are
going to have far better guess at it
than any of us but having said that and
as a dog owner myself if your dog's ball
goes in the river you say goodbye to the
ball and that you don't go in after it
and Nicholas seems to be a fairly
sensible person I don't think she would
have have done that she's also supposed
to be quite a decent swimmer and if you
did end up in a river you would just get
rid of the coach that the police think
has dragged her down
um it doesn't explain why her body
hasn't been found and more than anything
else just as a dog owner if you've got a
spaniel as Nicola did that those those
animals love water and if their owner
goes in the river I'd have thought the
spaniel would be straight in there after
her you wouldn't better keep it out so I
just I can't see this explanation really
being the full answer that we'll end up
with in the fullness of time put it that
way that horrible accidents do happen
people do slip and fall and get suck
down into terrible whirlpools and so on
um I don't think we've got the full we
haven't got the full answers yet and I
just feel terribly sorry for her family
that are you know have played me this
week in the interviews they've given
they're not
um Terribly Happy with perhaps the way
some of the investigation seems to be
going saying look there's no way that
she just disappears you know but yet
that seems to be what the police are
still saying she has just disappeared
yes her partner's saying that it's it's
uh as if she's just disappeared as you
say to thin air but but Mark I suppose
the police must look at every
possibility
um no matter how far-fetched it might be
well they must look at every possibility
but I confess this is part of what
troubles me a little bit about this uh
story appearing in lots of the papers uh
tomorrow morning which in various papers
is described as the police's working
assumption now I'm sure the police are
considering a variety of different
theories but assumptions are risky
things in investigations and the fact is
that just as Susie says we don't know
what's happened that's the whole uh
pointed issue in this story we don't
know um it seems like they seem to
attract down a pretty precise timeline
of large portions of uh the events
leading up to her disappearance and
there's a there's a gap in time which is
as you're unaccountered for but
assumptions can be risky things because
they can drive good think and they can
drive people to disregard other
possibilities But ultimately while this
is a huge story rightly and a you know a
very troubling mystery it's also a
devastating personal story every every
family's worst nightmare to have uh
somebody go missing without knowing into
that explanation and then have to try
and account particularly to the young
children who are missing their mum yes
terribly sad as we've said I mean one of
the things that they're looking at is
this um missing 10 minutes which strikes
me as being quite crucial now to the
investigation Susie
yeah it's what's in those 10 minutes and
of course if in an Ideal World if the
dog would be able to tell us if there
was some way of any of communicating
with Willow
um but I agree with Mark one of the most
devastating things that's gone wrong
with so many big murder uh hunts and and
missing person inquiries that I've
covered as a reporter the thing that's
gone wrong there's twofold first off is
the group think that he mentioned the
decision that it must be X therefore
that's what we're going to concentrate
on which means that you do stop thinking
about the other possibilities sometimes
that has happened in numerous
investigations and secondly when they
have a big lot of media attention uh
often at a time of year when other news
is a bit quiet perhaps and so the media
are really focused on something it it
kind of changes the way the police
investigation operates it shouldn't and
it's not the media's fault it's the
police's fault when they allow that to
pressurize them in the way they
investigate things but unfortunately
forces that aren't used to having a big
lot of you know media turn up and asking
questions and and going through things
they they can sometimes have the wrong
reaction to it and I think what Mark
pointed out there about having a press
conference saying this is our working
assumption
is it's not a wise thing to have done on
the police's part I hope they're right
and I hope that they they've got
everything discussed and that whatever's
happened to Nicola she didn't suffer any
great pain or anything like that but
um I think just saying that kind of
thing in public is probably not wise
Mark do you think it's it's premature
that them saying that anything
suspicious has now been ruled out
they're saying they're sure as they can
be that she did not walk away from from
the riverbank
we always have to bear in mind the
possibility that we don't know
everything uh in this discussion and you
know this evening on the show that maybe
the police know in their investigation
maybe they know uh I mean maybe they
have more indicators than the well aware
of however
if it is the case that they don't know
what's happened that remains the
conclusion
um I don't think you can responsibly
rule out
um other snores you can't rule them in
either I the the fact is we don't know
the police is the police's account the
official position continues to be that
this is unexplained and I think if it's
unexplained it seems as Susie says does
seem responsible to start rooting out
any other possibility they have
unfortunately been mistakes made in the
past
um and things overlooked
um in the past because people move to
working assumptions and they write
things off and I can understand
in that scenario as the family for the
family of a missing person in in in the
middle of a situation like this of
course the last thing you also want to
hear is a simultaneous message that well
we don't know the answer but we're
ruling out a whole range of different
things if they don't know it should be
the surely the question remains open
yeah that's one of the things you've got
the Press attention is that their desk
the police are sort of desperate to have
an answer to the questions and rather
than doing as much as suggested they're
saying well look we're ruling nothing
and ruling nothing out they're so
desperate to think of something and they
they go further than they should do
sometimes with their publics I I think
it's fair to say that you know there is
an extraordinary amount of pressure
particularly in the Modern Age on any
Authority any investigation like this
because we're so used to the idea that
you you hear people say this all the
time around circumstances like this you
can't just vanish and we're used to the
idea that everything's tracked that CCTV
CCTV everywhere people map their jogs
and their runs and they uh dial into
things all the time
um and it's probably more alarming I
think more challenging to the kind of
modern mindset than perhaps it might
have been previously that in previous
generations which puts pressure on but
as Susie said is the job of the police
to resist that yes let's move on to the
express and uh Susie Boris Johnson is
saying that he believes the
conservatives can win the next election
yes
um the one thing I think you could
probably well there is many things you
could probably say to find the rule of
Boris Johnson's prime minister one of
them is arguably the ability to talk
things up shall we say because I can't
say what I would actually call he what
he was talking most of the time
um and being the boosterism and being
positive and right everything would be
marvelous chaps off we go
um and this is just another example of
the Cloud Cuckoo Land that Boris Johnson
probably thinks that everyone else
should be living in
um it's notable that he he said this to
the renowned interrogator Nadine Doris
who obviously just let him say stuff
um without questioning him on for
example the polls and the science and uh
the general mood in the country all the
fact that he says the way to get back to
power is to cut taxes when he's only got
about 300 days left before the next
election that's probably not long enough
to haul the economy around and the last
person who tried to cut taxes cost us 50
billion quid not that long ago so we
could have done with some proper
questions of Boris Johnson when he was
talking about all this stuff but for
some reason Jillian he doesn't come and
talk to you or me he talks to Nadine
dorries who doesn't ask him these things
but Mark is this a misplaced optimism on
his part considering they are trailing
labor in the polls
I mean I think any rational Observer on
any side of politics would say it's
hugely challenging for the conservatives
but you also it's very important not to
prejudge elections you can never rule
anything uh in or out as a as a
possibility until polling day what I
think is quite interesting is the model
for this kind of Boris interview I don't
think is the years which he spent in uh
Downing Street I think they're the years
that he spent in City Hall one of the
most one of the periods that Boris
Johnson played very artfully in his
career and enjoyed a great deal was
being the prince over the water the
great what if while David Cameron was
leader and then prime minister he was
able to sit in City Hall across the
river in London uh from where from
Westminster
um saying various disruptive things kind
of lobbying grenades into the discussion
becoming something that people could
project could do all sorts of rebels
around conservatism could project their
um their fancies onto like well what if
Boris was leader maybe he'd do all the
different things that I might want that
I think suited him quite well I think
get built up how to build up and
maintain this profile which this is
certainly doing and of course it also
fulfilled it kept alive that option that
while you know right now I don't think
he frankly would like to go back into
Downing Street anytime soon he found it
pretty uncomfortable that old saying
appears if the ball should come loose
from the back of the pack and I was
having to scoop it up if it keeps some
option open then he's not gonna he's not
gonna feel sorry about that but
essentially is he is he right though
will the conservatives win the next
election
will they I don't know but not you I
have no idea okay let's uh let's move on
just fit in this last story
um Susie about the foreign office
whistleblower who's intending to sue
got just under a minute on this yeah
every time it's amazing I have lost
count of the number of times uh since
the 2010 general election that I've
heard various conservative Prime
Ministers and indeed I can definitely
recall that current Chancellor days
Checker Jeremy Hunt saying this is
Health secretary that whistleblowers
must always be protected and it's
amazing they were happy to say that when
the whistleblowers were exposing things
that had happened under the labor
government like the mid-staff Scandal
and not so happy when they're exposing
things that happen under the
conservative government now this isn't a
party political point because I would
suspect that the same would happen the
other way around as well but the fact is
if you want to protect whistleblowers
who are doing a public service to this
nation when they blow a whistle then you
down while protect them whether they're
blowing the whistle on you or someone
else it's called principle it's called
morals and this stinks
yes this is the exclusive interview with
uh Josie Stewart and said that former
colleagues felt their role was to
protect ministers some of whom were only
interested in looking good rather than
working in the interests of the public
but whistleblower is um as we know are
Anonymous and it begs the question how
they were tracked Tracked Down Mark very
quickly
well that is quite true I think this
arises from what was meant to be an
anonymous
um uh interview I had some involvement
around this same time as this story with
another foreign office whistleblower who
actually was somebody who formerly uh in
in a previous point in their career had
written for for one of our sites and he
was very very troubled by what he saw
partially around ministers partially
around unfortunately a kind of culture
of uh you know don't Don't Rock the Boat
among a variety of people in the foreign
office in official Dome as well and the
fact is it is incredibly intimidating
environment it's intended to be so in
order to try and deter people from
speaking out and saying what's right
just as Susie says this deserves proper
protection and ultimately that's from
all sorts of authority regardless of
party or institution yeah I'm sure we'll
be hearing much more about this uh
particular story Mark and Susie for the
moment thank you we are going to take a
break coming up we'll tell you why
Jeremy Clarkson might need to phone a
friend when booking celebrity guests for
the new series of Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire do stay with us
[Music]
thank you
let's um crack on with the stories and
leave the eye this story about a
shortage of HRT which is vital for the
many women to Simply function um but
women are struggling to find the hormone
replacement medication because of Supply
problems Susie
yes so what's happening is pharmacists
are spending half their days ringing
around trying to find the right
suppliers for things and this isn't just
HRT that this is about this is also
about
um some penicillin byproducts my
daughter had a dose of scarlet fever a
little while ago and this one kind of
treatment medicine for her amoxicillin
wasn't around she had to have the other
one because it's just in short supply
and there's lots of people have said
that some of the medicine shortages are
down to brexit due to the EU due to
pandemic and blah blah whatever it is
it's been going on for a very long time
and not only are there women who are not
getting their HRT and therefore some of
them are going to be finding it very
difficult to cope with daily life
um there are people who are not getting
perhaps the medicine and the treatments
and the regular prescriptions they're
also expecting and they're not getting
them at times they ought to that's going
to have a massive knock-on impact uh
further down the road with the NHS and
the rest of our welfare system that you
know really needs addressing because if
you if you don't get the medicine you
need when you need it when it's easy and
cheap and simple then you just have a
more expensive problem further down the
road that's harder to fix a mark
according to the eye drug manufacturers
are saying that they're frustrated by
The Silence from the government
yes and actually this is yeah the The
Ice headline describes this as a new HRT
shortage from my understanding this is
not a new shortage there was obviously
an initial uh bout of shortages of HRT
medication um about a year ago
um but even before Christmas there were
reports that while there were you know
there's been things like an official
registry created of which uh which
medicines in particular facing shortages
those entities have been becoming out of
date they've not been reflected by
what's happening on the ground and if
you're getting into what's now uh you
know breaking cover as a second public
major shortage in in HRT and as Susie
says in some other medicines uh that's a
sign that all the solutions that were
meant to happen a year ago have not
succeeded one thing I think is quite
troubling is remember when everything
was
urgent in the pandemic we saw some
really good Innovations I think in the
way in which The Regulators the mhra and
so on
um dealt with things like licensing
properly looking at Supply there should
it should not be beyond the wit of human
beings to say actually where there are
medicines that are licensed in other
equivalent
um regulatory regimes in other countries
we should be able to in some cases make
an exception copy and paste their
licenses accelerate approvals and help
to free up Supply it might all be
perfect but it should at least help to
deal with some of these problems yeah
but from what you're saying that seems
to corroborate the theory that the the
eyes are put out that there is silence
from the government let's move on to
this last story uh Jeremy Clarkson
um we said in the the the teas that he
might need to phone a friend when
booking celebrity guests for
um the quiz show Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire why so Susie
well having written something really
rather disobliging about Meghan Markle
in fact flat out hateful and having to
apologize for it quite extensively
um they're now finding that when they
come to book female celebrities for uh
the celebrity version of I Want To Be A
Millionaire they they all learn they're
rather phone a friend shall we say and
and not be on the air or anywhere near
Jamie Clarkson Because probably because
these are celebrities we're talking
about they feel that it would affect
their brand in some way and they don't
want to be um associated with him they
don't think he's going to do them any
favors to be on screen with him I would
like to put myself forward right now I
will nominate myself to go on screen
with Jeremy Clarkson Because I would
cough and go androgynous all the way
through and I think that would probably
uh get us all through it Susie you've
got your plan let's see if they they
give you that call uh we're gonna leave
it there thank you very much Lizzy and
Mark